so christina müller fragt was denken
jungs darüber wenn mädchen ihre tage
haben elf ich habe diese frage wirklich
schon so oft gelesen bekommen beim ein
video
ihr witz wahrscheinlich am hintergrund
ich bin nicht zu hause sieht ein
bisschen mädchenhaft aus ich bin bei
meiner freundin mir das nicht übel
es ist nicht mein bett aber anschließend
auch im schulausschuss ich weiß gar
nicht warum ich das überspitzt gesagt
auf jeden fall hat nicht mehr gedacht
hey komm du hast dann wirklich so
du hast nicht so daher keine fragen mehr
beantwortet und ich finde das ist
natürlich immer wichtig mit den
zuschauern zu interagieren
eure fragen jetzt werten zu nehmen und
die für euch zu beantworten
deswegen habe ich euch aufs netzwerk
gefragt ja ich stelle mir fragen das
ganze unter beim neuen instagram post
deswegen lohnt sich auf jeden fall bei
cnet und instanz zu zeigen schreibt
verbindung mit ja ich hab mir ein paar
fragen von euch rausgesucht ich hoffe
meine frage gestellt hat bist du dabei
ihr könnt natürlich unter diesem video
auch ganz viele fragen stellen
für das nächste fragen antwortet video
ich würde einfach mal sagen bei
zweckbauten live gibt es das nächste
fragen antwort videos irgendwann in der
nächsten zukunft ein zwei wochen drei
wochen was wenn ich ihr zeigen mit der
frage und die comfortline 40 39 fragt
was ist das erste an dass du dich in
deinem leben erinnert das ist wirklich
eine richtig gute frage ich hab grad
ohne scheiß etwa zwei minuten überlegt
und ich würde sagen dass erst dann mache
ich mich erinnern kann
das war in der ersten klasse meine ich
da bin ich nämlich ist das jetzt gut
oder schlecht ich hoffe dass schlechthin
durch es in der ersten klasse an was
erinnern kann ich weiß noch was nämlich
als ich das erste mal so mit 34 jahren
in einen kindergarten gehen musste ich
wollte nie weil ich wollte nie diese
zwei rechnung von ford weg und habe
immer geweint
daran kann ich mich noch erinnern davor
habe ich überhaupt keine ahnung was ich
angestellt habe
wahrscheinlich war es nichts gutes aber
die nächste wahl kommt von shirin und
sie fragt wie ist ein leben als youtuber
willst du lieber dyesols also erst mal
ich will auf keinen fall mein altes
leben so zurück dass ich jetzt halt nie
mit youtube angefangen hätte oder sonst
was bei youtube
wirklich schon so viel gezeigt so viel
ermöglicht gibt zwar situationen da
wünscht man sich es wäre schon cool wenn
ich einfach niemand entgegen
da wird eingelagert wird oder einfach
auf irgendeinem geburtstag von freunden
volt auf freunde sind die war ich vorher
nie gesehen hat zehn bar gefragt wird
wie viel man auf youtube verdient
das ist natürlich war ein bisschen blöd
ich muss halt immer davon ausgehen wenn
ich irgendwo hingehe wo auch andere
menschen meinem alter sind dass man so
gefragt wird wie viel verdient so wie
funktionierte und einkommen noch so
viele gespräche über youtube zustande
was man eigentlich gar nicht so möchte
aber eher das götter dazu ich bin auf
jeden fall lag damit angefangen habe ich
weiß jetzt nicht so viele coole menschen
die mich support würden danke dafür und
wir kommen zur nächsten frage die tram
oder gar keine ahnung sagt wie läuft
denn eigentlich mit chantal so ich will
nicht darüber reden ja leute die euch
sagen
chantal gibt es nicht mehr
schon hat mich betrogen
was also die gibt's doch aber verliert
sie öfter nicht mehr in irgendwelche
videos dabei einfach so hab ich nicht
mehr bestandteil geredet ich wollte
nicht ein bisschen von chantal
distanzieren einfach aus dem grund weil
auch viele standbeine videos schauen und
ich möchte natürlich nicht dass er
verteilt euch dadurch angegriffen fühlen
ich weiß du dir nicht deswegen gibt's
weil wir's anteil hat folge machte er
sich einfach schon wieder von elena
adwords voll glück du bist immer drin
ich habe das gar nicht gesehen aber du
warst ein kreativ und frage gibt es
einen weg finden und zwar gibt es ein
witz sinne sehr witzig wird es gibt
gerade schon bist du nicht sehr witzig
finde ich kann euch den einfach mal
erzählen vielleicht findet ihn ja auch
witzig und war also passt auf zwei
fließbandarbeiter arbeit am fließband
und treten sich gegenseitig in die eier
dann kommt der chef rein und fragte
jungs tut das gar nicht weh
und dann sagt der eine von denen höhe
warum sind doch nur stahlkappen schule
erfahren war nichts was also war halt
also das abteil frage ob an den eiern
wehtut und der hat das halt so
interpretiert dass der chef fragen
möchte ob es an den füßen wehtut aber
das tut nicht weh weil die starken zur
anhalt wir lassen uns also ich 540 und
das ist ja auch die schutzschicht so
kristina meller fragt was denken jungs
darüber wenn mädchen ihre tage haben
ich habe diese frage wirklich schon so
oft gelesen und ich habe mir immer
gedacht ein macht das datum ein video so
nur irgendwie kann man hier auch nicht
so lang beantworten dass es für ein
ganzes video aber viele von euch wollten
das wissen so ey ist das eigentlich
täglich für jungen finden jungs das
eklig oder lg steht ihr so dazu macht
doch dass mein video blablabla habe ich
schon wirklich sehr oft gelesen ich
nutze es eine kurze fragen und antworten
wieder retour setzt sich jetzt in die
mitte und herr euch sagen das ist
überhaupt nicht schlimm das findet man
als junge nicht eklig oder sonst was das
ist ganz natürlich und ihr braucht da
überhaupt keine angst haben darüber zu
reden oder sonst hast da es kann sein
dass das mit 14 vielleicht noch etwas
anders sieht als junge vielleicht findet
man interessiert sind
etwas komisch das weiß ich kann mich da
nicht mehr dran erinnern aber ich meine
das ist ja nix ist das hat er jedes
mädchen dagegen mit 12 13 14 oder so
kommt das ja vielleicht auch schon
weltweiten und deswegen sollte man dabei
nur keine angst vorhaben ist eklig
finden oder angst haben dass der erste
freunde täglich findet
sonst wird man ist ja dann eigentlich
auch froh wenn man als erster freund
dann vielleicht mal sex mit seiner
freunde hat gestern ihren tage bekommt
und dann halt nicht schwanger ist eine
mindest mit mordes nicht so gemeint
erfolg jetzt eigentlich gar nicht hinaus
wir machen einfach mal schnell weiter
mit der nächsten frage also es ist nicht
stimmte janker fragt bist du moment mit
deinem leben und youtube zu ziehen so
wie es ist ich bin auf jeden fall
hundertprozentig zufrieden existenten
zweiten nach köln empfangen da mein
studium an und dann wird youtube
natürlich von meiner seite her
auseinandergenommen ich wohne in köln
jetzt kommen die heftigsten videos
deswegen ist sie auf jeden fall zu
abonnieren und ich bin gespannt was die
zukunft bringen bin mega froh das ist
alles so läuft wie ich möchte irgendwie
klappt ziemlich vieles gerade und
natürlich auch wenn euch so danke dafür
und jetzt kommen wir zur letzten frage
glaube ich die kommt von nissan sie
fragt willst du mal ein fan treffs
machen oder hast du das schon mal
gemacht ich hab das schon mal gemacht
aber am 25.2 gibt's in oberhausen ein
cooles kassel meet and greet könnt ihr
alle kosten vorbeikommen alles dazu
erfahrt ihr im video was sonst wandern
kommt das ganz entstehen in kooperation
mit ca
also ich will etwas gar nicht zu viel
verraten es wird auf jeden fall megacad
und ich freue mich auf euch am 5 die
zweiten oberhausen ansonsten last noch
nach oben la für den beiden parks und
fragen antworten schickt meinen stempel
in form und im uk die vielleicht auch
wenn ihr bock habt und wir sehen uns
morgen wieder war und auch lustiges
video 30 menschen noch einen super
schönen abend super schön morgen mit ein
paar schönen nachmittag und liefert das
immer ich bin heute voll abgewählt